good morning it's april 7th here in
london
and yesterday was the craziest day at
london real history
we made a thousand dollars on the stream
i don't want your money
i've never asked for donations i never
will i don't want your money
[Music]
this platform is of the people by the
people
for the people but now we're getting in
that was phase one now we're doing phase
two
phase three and i'm moving into phase
four and lastly there will be phase five
this is going to go on for another ten
days until rosic and we're shutting off
uh we'll be gonna be closing down this
fundraising campaign very soon so again
we're closing this thing out on may 3rd
closing this thing out on may 3rd
and that is what phase 6 is all about
this is about the running costs
and so now we have fundraising for our
monthly running costs
today i am announcing my plans to become
your next mayor of london donate to my
campaign donate to my campaign